I feel like I must have dislocated my
shoulder or at least there is some
condition with my shoulder that makes it
like more easy to dislocate because okay
one reason I actually uh have not been
to the gym in a while
was uh was there was there was one
incident and Connor was there oh yeah
and I don't think I've ever talked about
this but uh so you know we were we were
pumping some weights and uh I believe I
was doing like a shoulder press yeah
like free weights I don't know if that's
what it's called yeah yeah we're doing
shoulders yeah we're doing shoulders and
I remember it was like I was like my
last my last rep okay it was like you
know we're doing a few sets of ten and
it was like I was on set nine and Connor
was like come on bro you gotta push it
one more you can do it I'm like all
right bro I bought this and I [__] I I
push it and then I like I don't know
what happened but for some reason I just
lost all of the
all of the strength on my left arm right
and then okay so I'm lying down right so
you're normally like you're kind of
holding beneath it yeah yeah so fast as
well yeah yeah so suddenly I just lost
all of the weight on my left arm and my
left arm just goes
yeah like that right and it landed it
landed
this like this close to my dick
and I I was this close to just not
having children because I I
mean it's funny but are you saying it
now it was funny but at the time it was
like there's a lot of weight that you
just dropped on your head like it's
pretty [__] bad
I don't know if Connor saw if I dropped
it on my leg on my dick but I remember
seeing Connor's face to be like oh my
god did I just see my mate his dick is
gone yeah did I just see my mate lose
his lineage right there like the online
ends here yeah because I I thought I was
like you know you're there and you're
like you're trying to help hold the
weight yeah yeah yeah and you're like oh
my God it was like realize how important
it was to to be better at this because
it was so fast yeah it was like because
normally you see like shaking and then
you kind of like yeah you kind of grab
it but it was like just boom yeah like
that it was just it was just instant and
to this day I think my my shoulder
slightly got dislocated because I can't
it didn't hurt or anything it just right
like all that happened was just like it
just lost uh all strength felt down and
then it just I could move it again so
I'm pretty sure my shoulder just got
disconnect located
but it feel it felt kind of weird you
know yeah because I've like uh because
I've I've never dislocated anything
myself but I've seen people dislocate
joints but like that I feel the
reactions are always varied like some
people I've seen where it's like I have
no idea like this is like this looks
really painful like you you think they
might have broken something and then
other ones that just like like it's like
it's a slight inconvenience like they
just got a splinter in them because I
remember like one that [__]
traumatized me and and this is like the
day I stopped playing rugby was I was I
was in high school and we were playing
like you know just in in the schoolyard
I think I was like 16 17 something like
that and like it's Australia so like we
love playing rugby and so we're like all
right let's split up into two teams you
know in the year and we had this one kid
in our year called Victor okay
Dutch dude right right we're like 16
years old this guy is 2 meters and 20
centimeters what big boy how is he
allowed to play rugby with the normals
big [__] boy all right you know like
100 plus kilos like built like a brick
[__] house but like 16. it's 16. bro
it's a Becky character yeah he doesn't
belong in your school like imagine honey
I'm recorder without the scars that's
what he looked like right Jesus but like
but but you know everyone was cool with
him because he was like he was massive
but he was a real gentle giant like you
know never heard a flyer yeah you have
to be right so we were like all right
well when you play rugby you obviously
want the British [__] house in your team
yeah so we had him on our team and we
were like well okay you're the biggest
yeah so I was like all right you're the
big boy you can you can be a forward and
uh there was this other kid uh forgot
his name but like he was you know one of
the cocky bastards in our in our year he
was like a little bit good at rugby and
he's like yeah I can take him on
whatever [__] two minutes 20. who
gives a [__] I can take him on yeah so I
remember the other guy got the ball and
he's standing in front of Victor and
Victor's like all right I gotta I I have
to stop I have to stop him okay
he had a Dutch accent yeah because he
because he like came he immigrated to
Australia right right so he had this
Dutch accent he's like oh I have to stop
him okay
and uh and you know you're holding the
ball and the guy's hand is out like this
okay you know to try and maybe like push
him out of the way but uh this other guy
was a little bit smaller than the usual
yeah right especially compared to
[__] Mr massive giant over here yeah
so what he does is he runs he thinks
okay I can bulldoze him so he runs
straight towards him with his hand out
like this right and then there's like
this point of impact and then he falls
on his ass drops the ball and everyone's
like oh wow dude you just got absolutely
dunked and everyone starts laughing and
he's like yeah and he lifts his hand up
and his wrist is just completely right
down his hand is down here it's just
completely dislocated but like and
everyone thought oh my God you just got
your wrist snapped like yeah it's broken
but he was just like well I don't feel
anything though so it turns out his
whole wrist just got dislocated but he
was like it doesn't hurt or anything
yeah but I looked at I was just like
yeah you can't look at that [__] oh and
what he did was he just was like all
right yeah I'm gonna go to the hospital
and just walked off it doesn't hurt yeah
I mean after you probably get over the
shock of it you probably like yeah all
right well I mean he's starting to
settle in yeah yeah
that's my life now yeah my hand's gonna
be like this so maybe if it's like
completely dislocated then you lose I
don't know I don't know yeah
it depends on the type
like ever since that happened ever since
I almost lost uh my entire bloodline uh
my shoulders never quite been the same
it's like did you ever go and get that
checked out you should probably get that
changed
I probably should
this is like my friend uh my friend in
my uh high school he he
um playing Cricket obviously if you've
ever played Cricket sorry Americans or I
guess yeah just about everyone else yeah
yeah unless all the Indian fans like
I've I've ever played in these
Australians British unite yeah uh yeah I
mean you know the ball goes pretty
[__] fast oh yeah and it's the
cricket ball it's like a baseball but
harder it's a cement block it's very you
know and and I feel like making school
kids play this sometimes is a horrible
idea
um and he was a very stoic type kind of
kid anyway like he didn't really get
faced by a lot and he was uh very much
into Boy Scouts and all that stuff and
every weekend he's like yeah I just eat
dirt and climb mountains and you know do
extreme sports I don't know whatever you
know
on um yeah one one time he would try to
catch the cricket ball with his hand and
it went wrong and it only like his
finger kind of clipped it oh but it like
instead of like pushing it back it kind
of like like made his finger here go
like this so it was kind of like [__]
and he was like yeah it really hurts but
I think I'm just gonna leave it and then
he tried to bend it back and like didn't
have much success with it yeah and then
eventually he just left it and after a
few months he was like yeah it's fine
but every time he held up his hand his
finger was like a little bit bent there
and he just left it like that and I
assume I assume to this day it's still
like that because he just never got it
like a A month's letter he never got it
like checked or anything he was just
like that's fine oh you know he's like
oh this is my identity now yeah I think
must be a nightmare
or really easy it's like I can reach the
enter key really easily with my middle
finger now he can reach two keys at once
now you know holy [__] [__] fly fed
Jesus Christ when you forget how to how
easy it is to get injured doing very
mundane things but also Sports as well
yeah but then I guess you also can't I
feel like a lot of the time being like
worrying about getting injured in these
kind of things you know and these freak
accidents like well I mean you still got
to live your life and do some things I
think I realized recently because you
know you know how this you know when you
reach your 30s you know that's when
that's when you know your body is just
like your free trial has ended yeah we
are going to we are going into the paper
you're smaller you're lighter if you
fall or get hit you know often the
impact isn't as bad yeah falling so like
when I went to Thailand uh this this
last time is like such a [__] minor
minor little thing but it was such a big
I guess wake-up call for me
um as someone now 32. so it's all I did
was I was sitting I was sitting on one
of those plastic chairs that we had at
uh that at the wedding and obviously
this plastic chair had obviously taken a
little beating I didn't know that so I
just all that happened was I sat down
plastic chair broke and I fell on my ass
yeah yeah and there is like concrete
ground on like on like the patio where
on my garden in Thailand so such a such
a minor stupid little thing but like as
soon as it happened I fell down and I
landed a bit awkwardly on my tailbone
and I was like it's fine it's fine don't
worry don't worry it's fine through the
pain
all I did was sit on my ass it's it's
it's all good yeah
um so like one day passes I wake up next
day and it's uh it's it's pretty painful
and I'm like oh do I do I go see your
doctor do I not answer I'll I'll see
I'll see let me let me let me just let
me just hope that it's nothing serious
I'm praying to God
this I I'm not going to get like not a
life's life-threatening but just like an
injury that an annoying little injury
that's it's really easy to uh I think
break or bruise that bone yeah yeah it
is so it's like different severities
um and so a week passes and still
hurting a little bit
I'm like bro all I did was just fall on
my ass how am I how is this hurting for
a whole week and then I had to [__]
Google it and then I was like if you
fall on your tailbone what uh what are
like the consequences of that because it
wasn't I'm I wasn't exactly in like
searing pain I don't think it was broken
it was just minor discomfort every
single day and I'm just like I swear to
God if this sticks for me because I sat
on the wrong [__] seat I'm gonna be
so [__] angry at God
like
I've been avoiding in injuries like my
entire life and all it takes is one
[__] plastic chair yeah I know that I
can't believe that chair just gave you a
Perma
my entire life like no broken bones no
major injuries versus one plastic where
does it still hurt now thankfully three
weeks later it is it is three weeks yeah
three weeks later yeah you bruised it
yeah I think I think I bruised it but
three weeks later thankfully now it is
gone but it was such like a wake-up call
to me that's at my age just the
stupidest thing can have long lasting
consequences even if it's not something
you think of like a stupid [__]
plastic I mean it's you know it's uh you
it's like like freak accidents that like
you don't know if you just hit something
at the perfect angle where something way
worse Could Happen than it would to
anyone else in the same situation yeah
yeah a thousand times over so I feel
like worrying about it it's like yeah I
know worrying about it is uh is and also
hey if it is the chair that does you in
that's how it is man at least you know
one of the 10 people who die from
vending machines a year or something
yeah yeah yeah that feels like what the
hell exactly so three ten people wait
something there's this x amount of
people die every year of any machine
there are more people in Japan who die
of getting crushed by a vending machine
then of shark attacks
it's not [__] up
that kind of makes sense because I feel
like there's way more vending machines I
have more chance of beating up a shark
than another machine
vending machine I'm done
um it's falling on me yeah my bad yeah I
mean yeah that just makes sense
statistically considering how many like
the vending machine ratio to person
ratio in Japan because yeah versus like
sharks in Japan it made me realize uh
talking about uh that kind of stuff and
like little injuries that like I find
that I don't know if I'm I feel this way
but like I feel like because I got hurt
so much as a kid doing sports and dumb
stuff that I I don't know if it's like
perspective or what but like I feel like
when I fall or get hurt and things now
it doesn't I mean it hurts more than
when I was a kid obviously but I'm like
yeah I don't worry about it too much
whereas maybe if uh some of my other
friends try like say uh skiing or
something the first time and they
haven't had that experience of falling
on their ass in a long long time it's
like yeah oh okay yeah this [__] [__]
hurts they take it not as well
um as maybe you would if you've had a
lot more experience falling over I don't
know if that's how it works but it feels
that way like I feel like if you've had
that experience where you've been used
to it yeah especially it's like skiing
where you're used to falling over a
bunch or snowboarding it's like all
right well it doesn't bother me as much
when it happens when I'm an adult yeah
right but when you see someone doing it
for the first time as an adult falling
over like oh my God this is a lot yeah
usually when your first time ever
falling as an adult you're like all
right you're like six foot maybe you're
like 200 pounds that's a lot of weight
it's further to fall as well
yeah yeah well I like I remember like
the one one of the ski trips we went on
last year uh most most Falls I was like
completely fine
um one or one or two of them will get
you there yeah yeah yeah and I remember
but I remember there's one four and it
was a pretty bad four and I fell over
and I was just laying down and it was it
was like I was like it felt like my my
entire body was winded oh yeah that
happens and I knew I knew that I'd like
not that I'd like I didn't position my
legs in the right way that I knew I
should have to kind of like make the
fall better so I had this oh [__] moment
where I'm like I know I'm on I know I've
completely [__] up that fall and my
body's still in shock did I do anything
actually serious I think I actually
remember witnessing that ball because it
wasn't like the last day right yeah yeah
yeah I remember witnessing that fall
from from a dis I was like chilling at
the bottom of this slope and I was
chilling in the cafe with I think Luke
and uh and I was like okay you know
seeing all the boys coming down because
I think you guys went for like another
round or something yeah and I was just
chilling and uh and in the distance I'm
like oh there's God all right he's
coming down oh he's going a little bit
fast and then you just eat [__] yeah
right
and I got worried because you just
didn't move
like it's like usually when you witness
someone falling on the Slime right
usually you know they kind of move
around they pick themselves back up
immediately like all right he's good he
just just fell into whatever yeah you
can just walk it off but I knew like
something was like happening because God
did this tumble it wasn't even a fall it
was like a tumble yeah like a full flip
and you're just like lying face down in
the snow not moving an edge and I'm like
oh my God I just he's dead like I just I
just witnessed the death and I'm dealing
it with a coffee just like watching this
[__] happen yeah and you're on the
ground for like a good like five minutes
or so right like I mean it [__] hurt
but also part of that was just me trying
to psych myself up to be like am I
paralyzed now have I broken any bones I
kind of want to I kind of want to check
but I kind of don't just in case just
like these might be my last moments of
like freedom from any major injuries and
I wanna maybe Savor this moment and then
I was like all right I can be my legs I
got yeah I'm good I'm [__] good
Jesus yeah it can be scary yeah it's
very easy to injure yourself I think
it's easy to forget the skiing and
snowboard and stuff like that are pretty
dangerous oh yeah wow those fun
activities and beer yeah yeah